so theme running through you young
filmmakers passion not only for life but
for the people you love it's great it's
making me want to call my wife but I'm
going to watch the hockey game after and
I don't want her to know this show is
over so I won't be making that call be
getting the drink our civil medicine I'm
not bullshitting I'm sorry are our
silver medal winner comes from a school
that has over the past few years also
been no stranger to our Awards made at
the American University in Washington DC
by director Ellen tripler dying green
tells the story of dr. Billy Campbell a
physician from South Carolina who is
dedicating his life to supporting a more
eco-friendly alternative to a normal
funeral that was really cool seeing it
up here I am really honored to be here
tonight and to be recognized by the
Academy i'm also really honored to be
amongst this group of filmmakers first
of all thanks to my crew who worked so
hard who are extremely talented and who
gave it their all without them I
wouldn't be standing here tonight that's
Kelly Donnellan Stephen tringali Emily
gains brigham Kevin wells Doug Burnett
and and that there's just a list of
other people goes on I want to thank
American University the school of
communication for their support and
particularly to my advisors John Douglas
for not giving up on me for tamaki
støvler for always being there for
believing in me and from my first
semester till today and of course Chris
Palmer who also was just always there
and ready to watch another cut and give
advice thank you for the center for
environmental film making and the Neil
fam
a foundation for supporting the film I
also need to thank my husband for had my
children for believing in my dream when
we got up and packed and moved back to
the United States so that I could pursue
this dream of mine and become a
documentary filmmaker I'm so grateful to
you for saying yes thank you and yeah
and of course to dr. Billy Campbell and
his wife for trusting me to tell their
story I really feel like this was an
important story to tell and I felt like
they just opened up everything to me so
I thank them as well thank you again to
the Academy